alors les avantages et les inconvénients
dépend du point de vue auquel on se on
se place mais l avantage principal c'est
que cela confère au système politique
une très forte légitimité du fait que
les principaux textes législatifs ou
constitutionnelles ont la plupart du
temps fait l'objet d'une votation
populaire
est ce que il y a moins de votants parce
qu'on demande beaucoup la vie des gens
ou sur une année oui alors la fréquence
des scrutins s'évader grosso modo quatre
fois par année au cours d'un scrutin au
cours duquel on demande de se prononcer
sur quatre ou cinq objets donc
effectivement il y a une sur
sollicitation du citoyen qui peut
expliquer en partie à mon avis c'est pas
à l'explication principale mais une app
on a une abstention relativement
importante puisqu'elle est de l'ordre
d'environ 50% selon les sauveteurs
mais on leur demande leur avis sera peu
tour et n'importe quoi alors tout et
n'importe quoi en tout cas sur des
questions extrêmement diverses qui vont
de l'abolition de l'armée suisse aux
vaches à cornes en passant par des
sujets très techniques dans le domaine
de la fiscalité des politiques sociales
des transports du génie génétique des
centrales nucléaires ou des institutions
démocratiques elle même la production de
la proportionnelle par exemple en 1919
des traités internationaux de très
grande importance sur lesquelles par
exemple l'adhésion à l'organisation des
nations unies de corps électoral a vu se
prononcer donc on peut dire que
effectivement ces scrutins part un peu
dans tous les sens et soulève toutes les
questions politiques et sociales qui
peuvent
survenir dans un état démocratique est
ce que le danger c'est un le populisme
alors le danger bien sûr le danger c'est
que ces usages puisse de la démocratie
directe soit considéré comme illégitime
pour l'instant à ma connaissance après 6
en votation qu'il y a eu lieu en suisse
depuis 1848 eh bien je crois que la
démocratie on suit ce n'est pas du tout
en danger bien au contraire
est ce que vous pouvez dire que l'udps
et c'est donc le parti de droite extrême
au suisse a réussi à se faire connaître
grâce ou à cause de ses consultations et
donc une vingtaine d'années c'est
incontestable que l'union démocratique
du centre une formation disons de droite
souverainiste que l'on qualifie parfois
de populiste a pu bien sûr s'appuyer sur
ces instruments pour porter dans
l'espace public à se trompe de
thématiques qui lui sont chères en
particulier celles qui concernent les
questions migratoires et le rapport
entre la suisse et le droit
international ou les institutions
internationales comme l'union européenne
donc vous pouvez aussi bien de parler de
l'interdiction de la bourgade
l'immigration de genre de sujet est-ce
que c'est 13 ans l'année comme des
balles oui alors certains débats sont
particulièrement polarisé j'ai en tête
par exemple l'initiative populaire votée
il ya un peu moins d'une dizaine
d'années maintenant qu'ils disaient
l'interdiction de construire des
minarets en suisse
il ya un arrêt de riz en effet portait
sur l'existence de deux de deux minarets
cette initiative a été approuvé par le
le corps électoral et les cantons alors
cela dit sur sa mise en oeuvre
soulèvera probablement des difficultés
il se peut bien que la cour convention
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pardon soit amené à se prononcer sur la
compatibilité avec la liberté religieuse
et l'interdiction des discriminations
mais c'est en effet une thématique sur
laquelle l'union démocratique du centre
ces profils et politiquement mais l'udps
et ce n'est pas la seule à se profiler
politiquement sur d'autres thématiques
l'extrême gauche la fin sur l'abolition
de l'armée suisse ou l'achat d'avions de
combat
les syndicalistes le fond on dans le
domaine des politiques sociales ou du
droit du travail
donc comme je le disais auparavant les
sujets partent un peu dans tous les sens
est-ce que les faits permet aussi c'est
justement que le peuple décide
deux choses qui ne sont pas forcément
compatibles avec les accords
internationaux que la suisse a déjà
signé alors la question peut se poser en
effet actuellement il n'y a pas de
juridiction constitutionnelle et
l'assemblée fédérale qui est compétente
pour valider les initiatives populaires
ne se prononcera pas sur
l'incompatibilité de ces initiatives
avec des engagements internationaux de
la suisse sous réserve de ce qu'on
appelle le droit international impératif
c'est à dire des dispositions du droit
international qui sont considérés comme
inviolable comme l'interdiction de la
torture l'esclavagé ou des choses sur
lesquelles pratiquement la communauté
internationale sentance qui n'est en
plus pas forcément de reste la peine de
mort est-ce que vous pensez que si ça
n'existait pas la démocratie suisse
serait bon call oui probablement
pour ma part disons même comme analyse
je pense que si l'on est démocrate
on doit assumer sinon le risque du mois
disons-le et l'hypothèse que le corps
électoral soit beaucoup plus fréquemment
et d'une manière plus approfondie
associé à la produites des affaires
publiques et donc la démocratie directe
en suisse alors il peut être érigée en
mythe démocratique de notre de notre
pays
mais je suis toujours surpris lorsque je
parle avec des collègues français qui se
méfie des effets pervers susceptibles
d'être entraînée par ce système qui ma
foi je dois le dire en suisse
approfondi la capacité d'un état à
fonctionner d'une manière démocratique
mais est ce que justement contre x suite
le peuple ça ne sous-entend pas que le
peuple et former éduquer à la chose
publique
alors cette observation est vrai on
observe en effet une distance entre le
peuple et les élites une dépossession
politique probablement d'une bonne
partie du corps électoral qui se
manifeste dans l'abstention mais cela
est vrai aussi bien pour la démocratie
représentative selon attendu citoyens
qu'ils se prononcent à l'égard de
programme politique à l'égard desquels
ils manifestent parfois et même souvent
beaucoup de distance
au contraire je considère que les
instruments de la démocratie directe du
fait qu'ils posent dans l'espace public
un certain nombre de questions tout à
fait essentiel à la conduite des
affaires publiques et bien c'est
absolument peuvent favoriser le
développement de l'opinion politique
puis d'une rationalité politique plus
largement partagée que lorsqu'elle ne
l'est que dans un petit cercle restera
de professionnels de la politique
est-ce que vous pensez que votre mot
votation référendum et autres
initiatives ses ex portable ou un
portable en france
il faut bien voir en effet que les
institutions et les usages que les
acteurs politiques font des instructions
sont toujours tributaire d'un contexte
particulier j'observe par exemple que
les états unis des états américains ont
importé les mécanismes de démocratie
directe au début du 20e siècle mais je
m'imagine
je n'imagine pas que dans une démocratie
libérale comme la france il soit
particulièrement problématique
ils ont apporté au moins le principe de
ces instruments de démocratie directe
quitte à les aménager
selon le génie propre de la vème
république et peut-être un sixième une
autre fois